um so i'll tell you um you know very much a technology development story um today hope i
can do this in seven minutes usually my introduction alone is seven minutes um so
these are my disclosures um so don't need to introduce this to this audience uh you know mds
and aml are incredibly polyclonal diseases and for that reason we are very interested in this
polyclonality, especially at the level of stem cells and pre-leukemic stem cells in those diseases.
And while we and others have focused very much on genetic heterogeneity and genetic markers
mutations to define subclones, there's other mechanisms of heterogeneity. And one of those
mechanisms is actually transcription itself. And what I want to point out here is that transcription
is actually very much a non-continuous process. And this is well known for a long time. We didn't
discover this. We didn't come up with this. So basically every gene expression locus that has
ever been studied shows that RNA transcription is not continuously occurring, but it occurs in
short bursts. And you can see this. This is data from our lab on the P21 locus with the live cell
reporter assay in collaboration with Rob Coleman's lab. What you can see now in this area under the
curve is that there's really transcriptional bursts, these peaks, followed by periods of
silence. And this is really how gene expression works. Ultimately, transcription machinery,
transcription factors recruit one and exactly one molecule of polymerase 2. And then this one
molecule of polymerase 2 is synthesizing one molecule of RNA. And then, of course, you can
have multiple molecules and you can have a burst of.
You can have five RNAs, you can have four, you can have three, you can have 10, but it's a defined
number of RNA molecules that are synthesized. And then again, there is periods of silence. So
transcription is very much a bursty process. What does it mean? So a few years ago, we asked a very
fundamental question, and that is, is observed heterogeneity that we all find and describe in
our single-cell RNA-seq studies, are those really describing true subpopulation diversity? Or is
some of that simply driven by the fact that it's a single-cell RNA-seq study? And if so,
is that really driven by the biophysical stochasticity and the bursting of the transcriptional
process? And to do this, we used a methodology called single-molecule RNA fish. This was, again,
in collaboration with Rob Singers and Rob Coleman's lab. In the interest of time, I can't go into
technical details. We published this, took us a while to figure this out and to do this on primary
cells, but you really get very robust assays that really can detect on an image, on an image, on an
imaging basis, single molecules of RNA in a cell. Because it's imaging-based, you get a lot of
information, accurate counts, you have subcellular localization, and you have the bursting
information. If you have more than one molecule in the nucleus in one spot, you know that's where
the bursts are occurring. And the only thing I want to point out here in the interest of time
is that we are able to, of course, detect all the well-expressed RNAs, but also, as you can see here
with hematopoietic subpopulations, we can reliably detect single digits of RNAs in the cell, so we're
seeing much more. It's a locus-based assay, so it's not genome-wide like RNA-seq, but we do see
transcripts that are well beyond the detection limit of what RNA-seq can do. Now, through live
cell imaging, we asked the question, are transcription states primed early in stem
cells, or are they still fluctuating, which is what we're trying to do. And we found that
we hypothesized, and so we did this live cell imaging and transcriptional assessment assay,
and what we found, I'll cut to the chase here in the interest of time, is that stem cells actually
are not locked into certain transcriptional pathways from the get-go, but that hematopoietic
stem cells actually shuttle between transcription states, pretty much what we had thought would
happen if you think about the stochasticity of the process. This is here described,
for the fluctuation between PU1, a very important myeloid and lymphoid transcription factor, and
GATA, erythroid factors, and so really what you can see is that stem cells shuttle back and forth,
so the same cell, dependent on the time of the assay, looks differently transcriptionally at
different time points. And, you know, this is just visualizing this further, so you have cells
that fluctuate in and out of PU1 high or GATA high states,
at any given time point, you can detect, you know, if you want a transcriptional positioning,
that doesn't mean the cell is staying there and is locked into, let's say, a PU1 high state,
but it can come back, so there's a constant fluctuation, not just at the level of from
cell to cell, but within the same cell, so the time point of the assay matters, and snapshot assays
cannot reliably predict, you know, where the cell was before and where it will be in two hours,
from now. Now, this is obviously very important, so we have now this amazing transcriptional plasticity,
and we now say, you know, we actually, we try to avoid the term "state" to some extent, and we more
describe it as a transcriptional space that cells and subclones actually occupy. Now, you ask, okay,
this is all fine, this is RNA, how about protein? And I hope this video plays, so we've also made
advances in the
visualization of single protein molecules of transcription factor. Again, this is work in
collaboration with Rock Coleman's lab, we use halo and snap-tagged proteins, and what you see
here in this video are single molecules of PU1 as they move around in the nucleus, and so really,
these are single transcription factor molecules that browse the genome, then you see some of them
that actually sit there, and where you can visualize the, you know, where they are sitting, or that they are
sitting on the chromatin, and then they move again. And what was surprising here, you can do a lot of
quantification here, imaging-based, you know, what's surprising to us, and you see this on the left side,
that only a very small number of molecules, around five percent of PU1 in this case, are actually
really stably bound to the chromatin, and 95 percent are really just swishing around and looking for the
next binding site. The other thing that was really quite shocking to us is we thought, okay, when it
binds, we thought it's somewhat more stable, and it's really not. And you see this in the lower
right, so the stable residence time, I mean, first of all, the majority of molecules upper right
binds only less than one second, so that's the browsing kind of movement, but then even the
ones that are more stable are only binding in the ballpark of 10 to 20, maximum 30 seconds, so it's a very
very highly dynamic on-and-off system. And so it's very very dynamic, you know, it's very interesting,
raises a lot of questions, you know, to what we're actually seeing in our ChIP-seq and Cut&Tag and
other data sets, but also it makes it amenable for therapeutic interference, and that's what I'll talk
about in my second talk later this afternoon, because as you all know, the transcription factors
and transcriptional aberrations
are one of the key features and hallmarks, in particular in pre-leukemic stem cells, and
are key mediators of the differentiation block that's pathognomonic for MDS and AML, and so,
you know, these are some of the factors that we identified over the years, and I'll talk about
this later in the afternoon session. So just to summarize, again, pathogenesis of myeloid
malignancies very much, you know, fundamentally polyclonal. I hope I've convinced you the transcription noise and
transcription dynamics contributes to the stem cell heterogeneity and plasticity, it's not just
genetics, and that single molecule methodologies are very powerful tools to get a handle on this.
And then again, the last point is the pharmacological targeting of transcription
factor dynamics and noise is fundamentally possible, and I'll tell you more about this
later this afternoon. Thank you all so much.